this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the chicky
science show where in this video we'll
be talking all about
sono therapeutics so we'll be addressing
questions
such as what is analytics how does
analytics work
what's the difference between
stenolytics and xenomorphics
and what current human clinical trials
are assessing the efficacy
of different analytics for different
age-associated diseases
and we'll also take a look at what we
can expect in the next few years in
terms of research in this area
and other areas of focus that we still
need to understand a bit better
so you could think of this video as your
ultimate guide to xenotherapeutics
and so an obvious beginning for the
ultimate guide would be a definition of
what xenotherapeutics
is and so center therapeutics refers to
the development of therapeutic
strategies
to target cellular senescence that could
have benefits
for aging and age-related diseases and
the reason that it's thought that they
have benefits
is due to the current idea that cellular
senescence
and the increase in senescent cells of
age are contributing to aging
and age-related diseases and so the
first concept that you need to
understand for this
ultimate guide is what is cellulosin
essence
and what are senescent cells well
senescent cells
are cells that have undergone cellulosin
essence but that doesn't really tell you
too much
cellular senescence is a cell state that
occurs in response to a variety of
different stresses
so that could be dna damage it could be
replicative stress
from replicating too many times and
shortening telomeres
oxidative stress or oncogenic activation
and so irrespective of the inducers of
cellulosin essence
there are some common outcomes the first
key response
is a cell cycle arrest so the cell stops
dividing
and this arrest is permanent and the
second shared response
is the secretion of a variety of
different factors
referred to as the senescence associated
secretory phenotype or the suspicious
more commonly referred to
and so the interesting thing with
senescent cells is that their biological
consequences
could be seen as beneficial or
deleterious
and so in terms of the beneficial
outcomes cellular senescence
is thought to be a tumor-suppressive
mechanism because it prevents a cell
that's
got some dna damage or some oncogene
being expressed
from further dividing and replicating
which could eventually form a tumor
moreover senescent cells are thought to
be beneficial for wound healing
and regeneration as well as playing a
key role in embryonic development
however senescent cells are also thought
to have deleterious biological
consequences
these include kind of paradoxically
tumor development
whereby the secretion of these different
inflammatory markers can generate an
environment that's favorable for tumor
growth more on from this
chronic inflammation of these different
inflammatory factors
could be driving the aging process along
with different age-related diseases
and another deleterious biological
consequence is if stem cells become
senescent
and so stem cells our cells that can
regenerate
and are thought to be important for
repair and replacement of cells in
different tissues
and so if they become senescent and stop
dividing it might limit
the tissue regenerative potential and so
to add a little bit to the complexity
we've spoken about this secretory
phenotype being deleterious
for potentially driving chronic
inflammation and different
age-associated diseases but the same
secretion of these different factors
is also thought to drive immune
surveillance whereby
the factors can activate immune cells
and bring them in
to clear senescent cells and get rid of
them and so this brings us back to
whether or not
targeting senescent cells could have
therapeutic potential
and so this brings us back to the term
centro therapeutics
and so far there could be considered
three different
branches of sonotherapeutics these
include
synolytics sonomorphics and then
lastly ways of activating the immune
system or modifying the immune system to
specifically target
senescent cells so exploiting the body's
natural
immune system to get rid of senescent
cells so firstly let's take a look at
xenolytics
so xenolytics describe pharmacological
agents
that can selectively eliminate senescent
cells
and so the key word here to notice is
selective as the idea behind synalytics
is that they kill senescent cells
and not your normal healthy cells so how
do sonolytics work
well various analytics strategies have
been developed
using a combination of different in
featuring models of senescence and in
fivo animal models
and the different compounds that have
been identified so far
seem to exploit the fact that senescent
cells frequently
upregulate genes that repress apoptosis
which is a process in a cell that causes
the cell to die
it's a form of cell death and so
senescent cells are very anti-cell death
they just kind of persist about
secreting stuff basically
and so the rationale behind different
synolytics is to inhibit the activity
of these anti-apoptotic proteins and to
instead drive the senescent cells
into apoptosis and so this is where the
selectivity comes from because only the
senescent cells
have this high expression of these
anti-apoptotic
proteins and so in normal cells it won't
really have an impact
at least that is what we hope is the
case and so this figure here from a
recent review article
nicely summarizes how we think current
analytics are acting in the cell
as in which different proteins it's
targeting to cause that senescent cell
to enter cell death
and so you will notice that there are
many different types of
ceneolytics including natural compounds
such as quercetin and physetin
and so these are both natural flavonoids
that can be found in different foods
and it's interesting to point out as
well that quarter tin
seems to act most effectively as a
sonolytic when combined with another
drug the satinib
and another thing that's worth
mentioning is why are we looking for
analytics in the first place
and that comes from previous work that
have used genetic models
whereby they can eliminate senescent
cells in mice
and when they do that and naturally aged
mice it's been shown in studies
to improve physical function and
increase lifespan
and so going back to cenolitic agents
the idea is to use
drugs or natural compounds that can
eliminate senescent cells
to circumvent the use of genetic
engineering to remove senescent cells
for humans
and so many clinical trials have already
been initiated
to assess the efficacy of these
different analytic agents
for the treatment of different diseases
and so far
it's already been shown that the
combination of the satanic question
has been able to reduce senescence
markers in a phase one clinical trial
in patients with diabetic kidney disease
and idiopathic pulmonary disease
and so as you can see in this table here
they have now entered into phase two
clinical trials
in addition to many other senolitic
compounds that are also in
phase one trials you'll also notice
though that many of these stenolytic
compounds have so far only made it to
preclinical models so
using mice as in vivo models
and i also wanted to point out these
galactose conjugated cenolitic
products which act slightly differently
as sonolytic agents
because instead of targeting different
proteins already in the cell
they deliver a cytotoxic agent within a
nanocarrier
that only gets degraded when there is
galactosidase activity
and so senescent cells have high
activity of
the so-called senescence-associated
beta-galactosidase
and so the compound would only get
broken down in senescent cells where the
cytotoxic agent would then get released
and then kill the senescent cells
selectively
and so that's definitely interesting
work to keep an eye on
so how is analytics different to
cenomorphics
well as an alternative to killing
senescent cells
xenomorphics are proposed to act by
limiting the detrimental impacts of
senescent cells
largely through modulating the
senescence-associated secretory
phenotype
so in a way trying to reduce the amount
of inflammatory factors that are being
secreted
and so the way to do this is to inhibit
the proteins in a cell that
drive the expression of these different
susp components
i'd say one of the key proteins involved
in this process
is the mammalian target of rapamycin
mtor
and so unsurprisingly rapamycin which
inhibits centaur
and has also been shown to extend
lifespan in both male and female mice
it's thought to achieve that in part by
reducing the inflammatory phenotype of
senescent cells
and so again we have a nice figure
demonstrating how vapormycin
is inhibiting mtor another agent that's
worth mentioning
is metformin which is thought to as well
have some semimorphic potential
by inhibiting the action of nf kappa b
which is another key protein
that is thought to mediate the
upregulation of different genes that
make up the senescence-associated
secretory phenotype
and so the reason that i mentioned both
rapamycin and metformin is that they've
already been approved for
immunosuppression
and for type 2 diabetes respectively and
so this table that i'm showing now
shows other sonomorphics and their
action
as well as their current clinical trial
status that's have in most cases
either been approved for different
diseases or are being tested
in pre-clinical models so ignoring the
fact that these xenomorphic compounds
may have a multitude
of effects on cells and within mice or
within our bodies given the definition
of cenomorphics to inhibit
the pro-inflammatory sas factors it
could be considered
at the moment that synalytics may be
more beneficial than semimorphics
and there are three key reasons to
support this one
the useless analytics could be used as
an intermittent strategy
or as dr james kirkland director on
aging at the mayo clinic
likes to refer to as the hit and run
strategy
and so basically it means that you could
use synolytics
every so often as opposed to the
potential continuous administration of
sonomorphic agents
where repeated treatments would probably
be necessary
the second advantage is that removing
the senescent cells
eliminates the possibility of senescence
bypass
so that refers to a senescent cell that
can then escape senescence
and often that's due to the accumulation
of mutations
and so if it can escape senescence by
having more mutations
it's likely to then cause tumor genesis
so that's not good
and then the last benefit is the fact
that so far there hasn't
really been a direct demonstration that
the sasp is actually driving
aging related defects basically just
saying how
it's currently quite challenging to
separate the effect of inhibiting the
sasp from synalytics
when they use different transgenic mouse
models
but it is also worth mentioning that
it's not known whether sonolytics could
have detrimental consequences
especially when used in advanced stage
when the organism or
or humans in that case have a higher
abundance of senescent cells
moreover it's not known if there are any
detrimental consequences to long-term
use of cell analytics
but that's also why we have clinical
trials in the works
i said the last strategy is to activate
the immune system to remove senescent
cells
and so basically to exploit the fact
that organisms have an
intrinsic senolitic system that we refer
to as immunosurveillance
moreover it's possible that one of the
reasons why senescent cells accumulate
in aged tissues is due to a decline in
this immunosurveillance
and so boosting the natural immune
mechanisms of senescent cell
surveillance
may have therapeutic potential in years
to come since this is why a lot of acts
of research is being done at the moment
now it's also likely that other
interventions
such as caloric restriction fasting
and exercise could also have an impact
on
senescent cell clearance or reducing the
sasp
however at the moment how these
different interventions impact
the number or activity of senescent
cells has not been meticulously studied
and in part that's due to the continued
limitations in being able to
define senescent cells and also identify
clearly when they're removed from the
body
i recently spoke about a research paper
that identified
an oxy lipin which could be used as a
strategy to identify
senescent cell clearance which could
help in understanding these different
interventions further
but again it's something that is
currently being heavily researched
so yes there are definitely challenges
to center therapeutics
in particular making sure that it's both
safe and effective
but to quote from the end of this review
article the next few years we'll see
whether
its promise is fulfilled exciting times
lie ahead and i agree i think exciting
times do lie ahead
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video
longevity technology longevity
technology delivers high quality
daily news and insights on research
investments and technologies
that extend health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters
and thank you for listening